we live in a society
where honor is a distant memory
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
justice league snyder cut video for the alternate
ending with the joker scene zack snyder had been
talking about a couple weeks ago before they
released the movie so this is all for the justice
is grey edition of the movie the black and white
edition of the movie so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there were a lot
of people that were surprised to find out that
there were multiple cuts of the justice league
snyder cut but what happened though zack snyder
revealed that there were about four different
versions of that ending scene with batman and
joker just going back and forth taunting each
other trying to one-up each other each getting
in the last word and the alternate version of
the ending scene he was talking about was the we
live in a society line that they included in the
trailer a while ago that everybody was going crazy
about in the regular version of the movie though
you watch it the scene plays out very differently
and the joker never says we live in a society a
while ago he said that he was going to include
that during the justices gray edition of the movie
but they just released that version last night and
a lot of you queued it up you probably noticed
that the black and white version on hbo max
seems like the exact same version of the movie as
the regular snyder cut just turned black and white
so a lot of people were wondering where this
deleted scene in this other joker moment that zack
snyder was talking about had gone well there's
actually a clip of him explaining how the scene
was supposed to go down in a recent interview so
i'll play that clip in a second because obviously
he's been going around a bunch of different
podcasts doing all these different interviews
talking about all kinds of deleted scenes and
alternate moments but the alternate version of
the ending is supposed to come around where the
batman harley quinn line happens and he reveals
that she asked him to kill the joker slowly and
it's batman telling joker he's most definitely
going to kill him once they accomplish their
mission and help the flash time travel back into
the past and try and change the timeline and this
is where they filmed a bunch of different versions
of the scene with the joker with them trying
a bunch of different takes and the scene that
they wound up putting in the movie is something
that jared leto actually improvised in the moment
so this is zack snyder talking about the deleted
scenes and all the alternate endings that they
filmed for this scene in the moment it's an
either or moment at the end of this batman the
harley quinn speech and you either go we live
in a society or we do what we did in the movie
and i just thought it's cool that i live in
a society needs cool but i also did very much
like the broken the tricked the vulnerable that
you see in the movie and so it's a trade-off
of not getting the vulnerable joker and one other
idea which is cool and i like it because that's
where jared did it and then he goes oh i have
another idea and then i think the way it was
scripted he said i'd have to look now because we
did like four different versions i think he says
something about like who do you think cried louder
the boy or the girl after he's you know something
like that right because you know they're kind
of like going like this and i just wanted him to
just give batman one more shot so as he explains
there were a bunch of different versions of the
scene of batman and joker each trying to one-up
each other that they had on the page each one just
taking another shot in the moment trying to get
the last word in the version of the joker harley
quinn robin scene that wound up in the actual
version the regular version of the movie that
we all just watched was meant to be him shaking a
little and being kind of speechless for a second
the reason zack snyder said he put that version in
the movie instead of one of the scripted lines one
of the four different versions of the scripted
lines is because he just thought it was cooler
to see a vulnerable joker and when's the last
time you saw batman actually surprise or shock
the joker he's always written to be the most
extreme character in any given situation the
most off the rails person but here is batman who's
doing that and joker just doesn't know what to say
for a second like wait what what did you just
say but remember that's just one of like four
different versions of that scene that they filmed
and per his explanation the way they had scripted
the scene the different versions were all just
versions of batman and joker going back and forth
talking about the death of robin in the death of
harley quinn like no robin's death was way worse
than harley quinn's after batman goes on nuclear
on him but zack snyder didn't want it to feel like
joker or batman won that argument that they were
having he wanted them to feel both like equals in
that moment but for whatever reason with all the
different versions they filmed the version of him
quietly shaking being kind of vulnerable for
a second wound up being the most impactful
so right now it just sounds like there will be a
blu-ray home video released eventually maybe by
next year and probably that's where he'd release
those alternate versions of the ending scene
unless he just straight up post them on his social
media accounts before that and the funny thing is
he also said in separate interviews is the studio
didn't want him to even film that nightmare scene
at all not just the joker scene they didn't want
him filming anything new at all any new footage
so he said he actually put up a green screen set
in his own backyard at his house because he wanted
to film this moment and it was supposed to be 100
his version of the movie that was the whole terms
of him coming back to finish the snyder cut and he
wanted to deliver on all these story lines in the
promise of the sequels so that's essentially what
the nightmare scene is there for that's basically
where most of justice league 2 takes place in the
nightmare future it's like a whole nightmare movie
essentially but this nightmare ending scene
that we see in the movie is just one of many
alternate timeline futures that play out through
the course of the justice league snyder cut story
like the vision that the mother box shows cyborg
of darkseid going around killing all the justice
league members then we see superman cradling a
dead lois lane then we see them flash forward to
the rubble of the hall of justice with superman
holding batman's cow like he's killed all the
justice league members and a killwog green lantern
there in the rubble that's meant to be a different
potential timeline than the one we see in the
actual epilogue so in the epilogue when joker is
taunting batman about not having the balls to die
himself to sacrifice himself and sending everyone
else to do his dirty work for him like robin the
death and the family stinger there and even he
joker himself says he's there on the team because
he's gonna do some of the dirty work for batman
i think it's implied in the moment here the way
this plays out with evil superman showing up how
they're trying to duck him is that joker has
come there to distract evil superman in some
plan that they have just long enough for flash
to travel back in time but joker talks about all
these alternate timelines so you do wonder how
many there actually are right now there are at
least three that we know about they're the events
of the justice league snyder cud movie the main
movie with them fighting steppenwolf then that
gunslinger standoff moment with darkseid that's
actually the second timeline it's not the first
timeline the first timeline is actually where
this original version of the flash comes from to
warn bruce wayne about saving lois lane during the
events of batman v superman this is meant to be
the first time he's time traveling into the past
so this batman scene is now the beginning of the
second timeline where things play out a little
differently but not different enough like the
reason why they still wind up with the nightmare
ending even though it's a different one zack
snyder explained is because flash was supposed to
travel back to one of two points in time and when
he came back this time during batman v superman he
came to the wrong one you notice during the scene
if you re-watch the movie again that's why he says
i'm too soon it's too soon he realizes he's at the
wrong point in time batman doesn't know what he's
talking about because he hasn't met lois lane yet
so he doesn't connect the dots the way his future
self nightmare batman wants him to so things still
play out similarly lois still winds up dying at
the hands of darkseid darkseid blames the justice
league and batman for it so that helps him turn
superman evil using the anti-life equation like
you remember the nightmare scene the way it plays
out she was my whole world like he blames batman
for lois lane's death that's mostly because of
dark side gaslighting superman so when we wind up
in the epilogue the nightmare scene here this is
the second nightmare timeline that is played out
and when the flash eventually travels back in time
after this moment here after he winds up getting
away from evil superman as it's kind of implied
at some point during the end of justice league
2 he travels back in time and creates the third
timeline and that's when they actually wind up
defeating darkseid like in that attempt flash was
going to pick the correct point in time to go back
to they successfully save lois from dark side she
never gets melted to a puddle of goo superman's
son because she was pregnant also doesn't wind up
dying superman then never falls to the anti-life
equation and doesn't turn evil and here's another
really cool detail that zack snyder just revealed
about justice league 3. for all of you who wanted
a henry cavill man of steel 2 movie i know a lot
of you still do obviously zack snyder said that
justice league 3 the final movie in the trilogy
was supposed to be a direct sequel to man of steel
like the third justice league movie would
have mostly been a superman based movie
most of the scenes most of the plot revolving
around him where you would have seen him become
the ultimate version of comic book superman all
while we see the full green lantern corps roll in
like the cavalry batman sacrifices himself dying
paying off the joker nightmare scene from the end
of the first justice league film or the justice
league snyder cut where he was taunting batman
about not having the balls to die himself and then
when lois lane and superman's baby boy was born
they would have named him bruce kent in honor
of batman's sacrifice and zack snyder said that
their baby wouldn't have had any powers like
superboy or anything like that but in 20 years
he would have become the next batman remember if
the justice league sequels had been made we would
have actually been seeing justice league 3 during
2021 like we would have actually seen it this year
in theaters and because zack snyder is all about
epilogues and ending scenes post-credit scenes
had he actually gotten to make justice league
three i'm hoping that he would have actually
done a short flash forward scene where you
actually see adult bruce kent wearing a new
cape and cowl i'm sure zack snyder is going
to keep revealing new details and how things
would have played out alternate moments and big
things that would have been going down during
justice league 2 and justice league 3. we know
about a lot of the story so i will still do a
video about the sequels in the next couple
of days at least by next week at some time
james gunn also just announced that they're
releasing the first official suicide squad trailer
tomorrow so of course i'll do a video for that
i'm also going to be posting my falcon and winter
soldier episode 2 video that'll probably post
first before the suicide squad trailer video
make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel so you don't miss any of those videos
everyone click here for my full justice league
snyder cut ending video with all the end credits
scenes and click here for my full breakdown and
easter eggs video for the entire justice league
snyder cut movie thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!